you guys remember when I said that
nothing is gonna go wrong well surprise
alright what is up reject nation let me
take this jangly wristband off it's John
Humphrey joining you once again I
apologize for this being a little late
I've spent most of my afternoon in good
old Century City figuring out how much
this is gonna cost me so I'm gonna make
do with my iPad for the moment we'll see
how this goes if a lot of people have
been asking me to check out the Florida
project trailer I don't know much about
this at all
I do see it's a 24 and you guys know me
so now we wasted enough time already
let's do it
[Music]
like that situation here open up
so the second week of the summer that's
already been a dead fish in the pool
fresh water bloom so much water
thousands of mother moaning great job
yeah if you're working who's looking
after moment you're not my father
I don't want to see you
[Music]
you don't think everybody knows what's
up yearly everybody
he's got to cry make you not tell me
you're talking to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
not safe
[Music]
let me do Oh hahaha
oh man first of all thank you guys for
recommending that to me after after
today of hers Ben's just watching that
trailer alone kind of warmed my soul up
a little bit so just a little bit about
the movie from what I can gather this
movie takes place over a single summer
and sort of tells the story of the six
year old girl and and you know the
adventure she has over that period of
time as well as her relationship with
her friends and her mother and things
like that just the experience of
watching this trailer alone I think this
is a terrific trailer I mean this
definitely gets its point across it
makes it seem very rousing and all that
I mean just just going by the trailer
alone I can't wait to see I hope I get
to see this I don't often get to see
these movies the movies that I I love
stuff like this and I really like
getting to go see it and you know just a
lot of the time there's this bigger
stuff to check out things that we review
are usually the bigger things I love
movies like this I mean I'm a big fan of
life II movies as I like to call them
I'm a big Richard Linklater guy
something about a story centered around
children is always fascinating to me
especially in this environment where it
doesn't look like the kids are going to
be overly adult you know overly
precocious or smart mouths or anything
like that it wasn't the first thing that
struck me but what I kind of appreciated
most about this is the fact that it does
look like a really natural story when it
comes to the children that's magical
when when filmmakers can pull that out
because it's hard to do mad respect to
the young actresses in here they look
like they're doing a terrific job I mean
every shot at least of the the children
looks really touching and really cute
and moving all at the same time and
Willem Dafoe I like a good creepy Willem
Dafoe role or a good kooky Willem Dafoe
role but I really enjoy when he gets to
do movies like this one when he gets to
show the more personal side of his
acting ability you know when he gets to
play more of a regular guy and he looks
like he definitely bring a heart and
soul into this movie that's something
I've come to actually appreciate because
of actors like Willem Dafoe you know
like I like character performances I
like playing characters myself people
like that it's kind of held
me to appreciate what's great about when
a character actor can really just give a
great human performance another aspect
of this show that grabbed me and it kind
of goes into the whole depiction of
childhood thing but a lot of the pull
quotes had allusions to the idea of
humanity
you know which is something that I
always really value and appreciate some
my favorite movies kind of have that
spirit you know kind of explorations of
humanity I haven't seen tangerine yet or
any other Shawn Baker's work but I mean
that is something that really pulls me
into this and it really feels like it
just from the footage they're showing us
this takes place in Florida near Disney
World and just even looking at the
little complex therein though it seems
like there's a lot of potential for
interesting side characters and stuff a
few of which we actually do see in the
trailer so that's another thing
especially in these kinds of movies that
I tend to relish is the attention to
detail when it comes to the side
characters it is an indie movie trailer
but you know it won me right off the bat
with that cute little scene in the in
the lobby where they're tripping the ice
cream and they're bantering back and
forth it looks like there's a lot that's
going to be very sweet and cute there's
probably going to be some humor but
there's also probably going to be some
pretty serious drama when it comes right
down to it it's a single-mother
situation it looks like and Bria vinay
hey or Vinay I'm not exactly sure how to
pronounce her name but she plays the
mother to my knowledge this is her first
film and it seems like a substantial
role for her even if the children are
like the main focus of the movie I mean
you know she's going to factor in and
you know this she and Willem Dafoe are
probably going to share a lot of their
plot time together I would imagine and
I'm really excited to see this actually
of all the Indies I've seen trailers for
lately this one you know kind of served
me up in a way that made me want to seek
it out ASAP so yeah thank you guys again
for recommending this I really
appreciate it I'm actually serious like
this did brighten up my day getting to
watch this and I'm really excited about
this y'all know me I'm a big 824 fan at
least at the moment you know I think
they got really good taste they have a
great track record if I see their bumper
I'm definitely at least going to check
it out and this is the kind of movie
that you know one day I hope I might be
able to make maybe with a little more
genre elements
on top of it but I've got a couple story
ideas and sent around children and
seeing something like this you know
inspires me for that so um yeah I can't
wait to see this movie
yeah so what do you guys think gee are
you looking forward to the florida
project what do you guys think of this
hit the comment box let me know what
you're up to and as always you can
subscribe to the real Rejects hit that
notification bell to get notified
perhaps whenever viewer video is out I
am Det John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram
we got a patreon community set up come
on over there patreon.com slash the real
rejects got a lot of fun stuff and
exclusives and things like that
t-shirts available in our Spreadshirt
store thank you very much for watching
hopefully tomorrow is smoother peace